you probably know that plenty of
colleges offer classes online but if
students need little extra help more and
more them are finding it now for free on
YouTube
Kip doe shows us what could be the next
generation of online learning going to a
traditional old school is well old
school this is the worldwide
headquarters of the Kahn Academy
inside this converted walk-in closet
could be the future of Education can do
here is just distribute this X plus 2y
onto each of these terms with a headset
an electronic pen and a zest for
learning Sal Kahn records short
bare-bones 10-minute educational videos
and post them on YouTube no big deal
until you realize there are more than
1500 of them covering everything from
basic addition to advanced linear
algebra and here the King of Prussia
French history and Ponzi schemes
economics mixed with current events
seventy thousand people view his
bite-sized videos every day at their own
pace all for free at the other day what
makes this fun for me is the idea that
as many people as possible could benefit
from it Kahn started recording videos
back in 2006 to tutor an out-of-state
relative since then it's exploded and
last year he left his lucrative job as a
hedge fund analyst and lives off
donations to Khan Academy the 33 year
old says the videos can free up teachers
to focus on teaching instead of
lecturing so the teacher says go home
watch these videos and then when we come
to class the next day you would have
already watched the lecture I don't have
to do that broadcast lecture to you in
the classroom and will actually do your
homework in the classroom accessible
cheap effective and sustainable teaching
for a wired generation it is making
people think hard about what is the
proper role for technology in the
classroom so I do hope it starts a bit
of a revolution but I don't know if I
can call myself a revolutionary call it
education 2.0 and we are done in
Mountain View KITT doe